Hey there, and thanks for stopping by!
My nameis Bradley Knapp,
and I'm one of the product managers here at IBM Cloud,
and the questionthat we're trying to help you answer today is:
what is the difference between a bare metal with
a hypervisor on it and a dedicated host?
because the underlying concept is pretty similar,
but theexact use-cases are going to be very different.
Both bare metals with hypervisors and
dedicated hosts have advantages.
They also have some disadvantages,
and so selectingthe right one to solve your workload needs
is going to be essential and critical in solvingyour problems,
because even though they do look and act and feel kind of the same,
those addedbenefits, those added drawbacks, they're going to make the decision for you.
And so, if we startfrom the very beginning, we need to think about a cloud compute host,
because that's the commonelement that every compute offering in cloud has.
So, on this side we're going to have ourbare metal with the hypervisor.
On this side we're going to have our dedicated host.
And so,let's start out with our actual host.
This is the physical compute host with the sockets and the RAMand the processors
in the cloud data center that you build on top of.
So, we're going to startwith our boxes, with either a bare metal with a hypervisor or dedicated host.
Those boxes arethe same. The underpinning compute is the same.
The difference is who runs the hypervisor.
Onbare metal with the hypervisor,
(this is going to be our hypervisor layer up here, HV),
thathypervisor is run by you, it's run by the client.
It gives you all of the control, all of thetweaking, that you're used to having on-  premises,
and so you really can get in and manipulate that
hypervisor to make the box do whatever you want.
Over on our dedicated hostside, we again have that hypervisor layer thatstays on top,
but the cloud provider runs this one.
And so we're going to apply all of our knowledge, all of our best practices, to this hypervisor.
We're going to take that complexity away from you.
We're going to take care of that, so that you
can focus just on the virtual server instances (VSI).
And so, when it comes time to deploy those VSIs
onthe dedicated host, you just tell us what kind of VSIs and how many you want,
and then we schedulethem against the hypervisor and place them on it for you.
So, you're going to have virtualserver 1, virtual server 2,
virtual server 3, so on and so forth, until you fill up thebox.
On the bare metal with the hypervisor side, slightly different concept
because, ratherthan you telling the cloud provider, "I would like to schedule these",
you're going totake care of all of this yourself.
You're going to interact with that hypervisor layer directly
to schedule those virtual servers yourself.
Now, why would you ever want to do this?
Well, becauseit does allow you for greater efficiency.
If you want to do what's called "over-commit", where
you're going to have a single processor thread,
but you're going to commit that to several
different virtual servers to using pooling,
so that you can get greater computecapacity by taking advantage of this host,
you can do that on a bare metal with a hypervisor.
On the dedicated host,
we don't have the ability to allow you to control what level of over-committhere is,
but when you're on the hypervisor, you make all those decisions yourself.
Also, becauseyou have access to this hypervisor,
it allows you to do a level of monitoring and a level of logging
that, generally speaking, cloud providers don't make available on dedicated hosts.
It alsoallows you to back up your virtual machines directly through that hypervisor layer,
plugginginto the API of that hypervisor.
Whereas, on a dedicated host, if you want to back up a virtualserver,
you have to use the cloud provider's APIs.
So, again with the bare metal with thehypervisor on it,
the big benefit is that you have granular control of everything you want to do.
Youcan over-commit VCPUs, you can over commit RAM, you can over schedule the box
so, if it normallywould only hold 5 VSIs, you can make the decision to put 10 on it.
Because you know yourworkload best, and you can make those decisions.
On the dedicated host, because the cloud provider
is running that hypervisor just like it does
any other hypervisor in the fleet, we're going to
abstract some of that control away,
we're going to take care of that for you.
But the benefit thatgoes along with it
is it means that you don't have the added complexity
that comes along withmanaging that bare metal server on your side.
So, it really does matter, and the decisionpoint is: how much control do you want?
How much control are you willing to give up, and how
much simplicity do you want?
Because there's no doubt a dedicated host is a simpler model for youto run
than a bare metal with a hypervisor is,
but with that simplicity comes a loss of control
and a loss of the ability to go in and tinker with each of those individual settings.
Thank youso much for your time today.
If you have any questions, please drop us a line below.
If youwant to see more videos like this in the future,
please do like and subscribe and let us know.
And, don't forget, you can grow your skills and earn a badge with IBM Cloud Labs,
which arefree, browser-based interactive Kubernetes labs,
that you can find more information
on by looking below. Thanks again!